what's going on guys today we're going
over the spoilers for my hero academia
chapter 291
which reveals more information on the
past of both derby
and hawks we also got confirmation on
the true color
of toyotaroki's hair as it seems that
hirokoshi is trying to fix the
differences between the anime and the
manga
just before we get into it be sure to
subscribe for more spoiler videos like
this
and remember that every sunday on twitch
i do a page by page reaction to the full
official translation i really enjoy
doing those streams because the
discussion in the chat is always great
so yeah be sure to stop by on twitch
this sunday okay so the name of this
chapter is thank you for being fine
which i suppose has two different
meanings the first and most obvious
reference
is towards the end of the chapter in
which dabi goes in to attack endeavour
and thanks his father for being fine up
until today and this is presumably
because you know debbie wants to attack
him and
possibly kill him personally on the
other hand
i'm sure endeavour is internally
grateful that his son is still alive
because you know
for all these years endeavour thought
his son was dead so to see that he is
alive
and well i guess he would also be
thinking in his head
thank you for being fine something
similar to that anyway the chapter kicks
off with an image of a young toyotaroki
standing up and at this point he's
probably around 11 or 12 years old
we can see flames raging behind him and
the narration states that toya died
inside a fireproof room
according to the fan translations this
room reached a temperature
of over 2000 degrees and it's implied
that endeavour was not with toya
when the accident occurred after this
the only thing that remained of the
eldest todoroki sun
was a piece of his lower jaw bone which
was found and
that's pretty horrific it's still
unclear how toya survived this accident
although my theory is that a third party
was involved
and pulled his body out from the flames
that way only his bone remained which
would make everyone else think that the
rest of his body was incinerated
the next scene shows us an even younger
version of toya
and this panel was really interesting
because he actually has a smile on his
face
during training at this point his hair
is red but endeavour notices that some
part of his hair
is actually starting to turn white toya
tells his dad not to worry about this
and arcs endeavor to teach him his
ultimate move which of course is
prominence burn
in the next panel we see endeavour with
a smile on his face
which shows that you know endeavor and
toyah did actually have
some kind of good relationship at one
point because endeavour mentioned the
colour of toya's hair
it is now officially a real plot point
so the anime has no choice but to make
dabbi's hair white
when we get this reveal previously the
two times we've seen
toya's hair in the anime his hair has
been red whereas in the manga it has
consistently been white
even in the scene which was shown in the
anime in the chapter last week
we got our first indication that toya's
hair changed color
during this panel and this probably
happened due to stress of all the
training
or maybe raised jeans were starting to
kick in
let me know which one you think it was
down below but yeah either way the fact
is
toyo was born with red hair but it
turned white after a while
the narration continues and it describes
toya as someone with stronger firepower
than his father
but lacking the icy power to neutralize
his overheating
ray suggested to endeavour that she
should have more children so that the
siblings could support each other
which resulted in fiumi being born
however fiumi only possessed the ice
quark
while endeavour wished for a child with
a half-hot half-cold quirk
he wasn't angry at this time because
toya still had more talent than he did
and he believed that if he poured all
his energy into this child
then toyo would fulfill his ambitions
the chapter then moves back to the
present day
and we see debbie still standing on
giganto making his back
while shoto and endeavour are just
looking up at him according to the fan
translations
endeavour doesn't believe what toya said
but then the eldest todoroki son
mentions how he did a dna test
using blood he got from endeavour during
the pro hero arc
the dna test proved that there was a
99.9
match between derby and endeavour and in
fact this test was shown as part of the
broadcast
that dabby was sending to the whole of
japan we see that natsu witnesses this
broadcast on his phone
and understandably his face is in
complete shock
meanwhile fumi is teaching a class of
students
but is interrupted when someone burst
into the classroom to tell her the news
in the middle of a random city in japan
we can see that david's broadcast is
even on the big public screens so it
just shows you that literally everyone
is seeing this
toya asks the public if someone like
endeavour is worthy of the title of
number one hero
when he has such a dark past and when
he's a person who only ever thinks about
himself
the scene moves over to endeavour's
biggest fan who is the kid from the pro
hero arc
at first he didn't want to believe the
broadcast but then we see him start to
scream
as darby continues to reveal more
information about the heroes
at this point he's now moving on from
talking about endeavour
to talking about hawks and dabi
broadcasts the moment
in which horse kills twice to the entire
country
i think it's important to remember that
hawks had his feathers completely bugged
with all these different cameras
and so skeptic probably just acquired
the footage of hawks killing twice
by just checking the recent recordings
from one of his feathers
dabby begins to rub it in by saying that
not only did hawks kill
twice he also killed best genus and as
if that wasn't enough
toya then continues and reveals that
hawks's father
was a villain which is something i've
suspected for a long time
back in the endeavor agency arc it was
mentioned how endeavour once captured a
thief named takami
and as we all know you know hawke's last
name is also takami according to darby
hawks's father was a serial killer and a
thief before endeavour captured him
which is possibly the reason why hawkes
idolizes endeavors so much
now if we just take a step backwards
dabi has exposed the top two heroes
at a time when faith in heroes is
already you know it's already on the
decline
i mean we had the incident during the
pro hero arc and then we had deku city
during the maven academia arc
and then i mean in in the present day we
have gigantomachia
destroying countless cities so faith was
already shaken
so the fact that he's now exposing the
top two guys
yeah it's not a good time for the heroes
back on the battlefield
endeavour is just too shocked to even
move a muscle
and shoto screams at him that you know
he needs to move we see that shoto has
tears in his eyes
as he yells an endeavor to protect
midoriya and the others
while he and neduri will deal with derby
during the last few chapters
shoto and neduri have definitely become
a dream team that i just never
imagined would happen toya then jumps
off giganto machia
and despite his frail body he begins to
activate the prominence burn attack
this is of course the ultimate move
which he asked endeavour to teach him
during the flashback
um but honestly we've never seen a
prominent sperm with blue flames before
so it's possible this is the strongest
version of the attack that there has
ever been
as dabby approaches he thanks endeavour
for being fine up until today
but as he gets closer we see some steel
wires begin to smash into the ground
as even gigantomachia begins to fall
over
these steel wires are the work of best
genus
who literally jumps out of the jet he
was in alongside the uh the wires
themselves
the chapter ends with genus saying that
he is returning to hero work
starting today and i'm sure debbie will
be super pissed to see that genus is
actually still alive
i guess he has no choice but to kill
best genius in the next few chapters
to uh to make himself not look like a
liar and yeah guys those were the
spoilers for chapter 291
as usual let me know what you think in
the comments down below and don't forget
to check out the live reaction to the
official chapter
on sunday next week there won't be a new
chapter
as harakoshi is taking a break but there
will still be other videos on this
channel obviously
so be sure to have your notifications on
and you know hit that sub button if you
haven't already
until the next one peace out